thank you thank you so much hello
Estonia tere Asti Thank You Oscar for
your wonderful introduction and for
representing the talent and the energy
and the optimism of today's Estonia
especially its young people and Oscar
sitting next to his father and his
father and I agreed that we're getting
grey so we have to make sure that
somebody's coming up behind us
please give Oscar a big round of
applause for the great job that he did
to present ill v's and distinguished
guests to the people of Estonia it is a
great pleasure to be with you in this
historic city in this beautiful land I
thank you for the incredible hospitality
that you've shown me today I understand
the weather is always like this my only
regret is that I missed this summer's a
la lo Pido and I'll try to come back
next time and and catch it I bring with
me the friendship of the American people
and I'm honored to be the first
president United States to deliver an
address like this to the people of
Estonia I just had the opportunity to
meet once again with the presence of all
the Baltic States and I thank a
president of Latvia and Lithuania for
being here we are joined by friends from
throughout the region and I want to say
a special welcome to everyone watching
this out in Freedom Square and I'm
especially pleased to see so many young
people here today because like Oskar you
are fulfilling the dream that your
parents and grandparents struggled for
but could only imagine and that is
living your lives in free and
independent and democratic Baltic
nations that dream of freedom endured
through centuries of occupation and
oppression it blossomed in independence
only to have it stolen by foreign pacts
and secret protocols it survived the
mass deportations that rip parents from
their children
it was defended by forest brothers in
their resistance and sustained by poets
and authors who kept alive your
languages and cultures and here in
Estonia it was a dream that found its
most eloquent expression
in your voices on a grassy field not far
from here
when Estonians found the courage to
stand up against an empire and sing land
of my father's land that I love and
Hinds fought who's here today spoke for
the entire singing revolution when he
said one day no matter what we will win
and then exactly 25 years ago people
across the Baltics came together and one
of the greatest displays of freedom and
nonviolent resistance that the world has
ever seen
on that August evening perhaps two
million people stepped out of their
homes and join hands a human chain of
freedom the Baltic way and they
stretched down highways and across
farmlands from Tallinn to Riga to
Vilnius they lit candles and they sang
anthems old men and women brought out
their flags of Independence and young
parents brought their children to teach
them that when ordinary people stand
together great change is possible here
in Estonia when people joined the line
the password was freedom as one man said
that day the Berlin wall is made of
brick and concrete our wall is stronger
and it was within months that wall in
Berlin was pushed open the next year the
Baltic people's finally voted in
elections and when the forces of the
past made their last grab for power you
stood up lithuanian space down tanks
Latvians manned barricades here in
tallinn citizens rushed through the TV
tower to defend the airwaves of
democracy you won you reclaimed your
countries and in your new constitution
you declared the independence and
sovereignty of Estonia are timeless and
inalienable but the people of the Baltic
nations also knew that freedom needs a
foundation of security so you reached
out to join the NATO alliance and we
were proud to welcome you as new allies
so that
those words of your constitution your
timeless independence will always be
guaranteed by the strongest military
alliance the world has ever known
today people working to build their own
democracies from Kiev to Tunis look to
you for inspiration your experience
cautions that progress is neither easy
nor quick here in the Baltics after
decades of authoritarian rule the habits
of democracy had to be learned the
institutions of good governance had to
be built economies had to be reformed
foreign forces had to be removed from
your territory
and transitions of this magnitude are
daunting for any nation but the Baltics
show the world what's possible when free
peoples come together for the change
that they seek and in that great contest
of ideas between freedom and
authoritarianism between Liberty and
oppression your success proves like that
human chain 25 years ago that our way
will always be stronger we're stronger
because we're democracies we're not
afraid of free and fair elections
because true legitimacy can only come
from one source and that is the people
we're not afraid of an independent
judiciary because no one is above the
law we're not afraid of a free press or
vibrant debate or a strong civil society
because leaders must be held accountable
we're not afraid to let our young people
go online to learn and discover and
organize because we know that countries
are more successful when citizens are
free to think for themselves we're
stronger because we embrace open
economies
look at the evidence here in Estonia we
see the success of free markets
integration with Europe taking on tough
reforms you've become one of the most
wired countries on earth a global leader
in e-governance and high-tech startups
the entrepreneurial spirit of the
Estonian people has been unleashed and
your innovations like Skype are
transforming the world and we're
stronger because we stand together this
year we celebrate the 10th anniversary
of the Baltics in NATO a decade ago
skeptics wondered whether your countries
were up to the task and today they need
only look at our training exercises
where our troops grow even stronger
together shoulder to shoulder they can
look at Afghanistan where our forces
have sacrificed together to keep us safe
and where in just three months the
largest operation in NATO history will
come to an end as planned there is no
doubt the Baltics have made our alliance
stronger and your progress reflects a
larger truth because of the work of
generations because we stood together in
a great alliance because people across
this continent have forged a European
Union dedicated to cooperation and peace
we've made historic progress towards the
vision we share a Europe that is whole
and free and at peace and yet
as we gather here today we know that
this vision is threatened by Russia's
aggression against Ukraine it is a
brazen assault on the territorial
integrity of Ukraine a sovereign and
independent European nation it
challenges that most basic of principles
of our international system that borders
cannot be redrawn at the barrel of a gun
that nations have the right to determine
their own future it undermines an
international order where the rights of
peoples and nations are upheld and can't
simply be taken away by brute force this
is what's at stake in Ukraine this is
why we stand with the people of Ukraine
today
now let's put to rest once and for all
the distortions or outdated thinking
that has caused this crisis our NATO
alliance is not aimed against any other
nation we're an alliance of democracies
dedicated to our own collective defence
countries like Estonia in Latvia and
Lithuania are not post-soviet territory
you are sovereign and independent
nations with the right to make your own
decisions no other nation gets to veto
your security decisions the protests in
Ukraine on the Maidan
we're not led by neo-nazis or fascists
they were led by ordinary Ukrainians men
and women young and old who were fed up
with a corrupt regime and who wanted to
share in the progress and prosperity
that they see in the rest of Europe and
they did not engage in an armed seizure
of power after an agreement was brokered
for constitutional reform the former
president then abandoned his office and
Parliament endorsed new elections so
that today Ukrainians have a new
democratically elected president and I
look forward to welcoming president
poroshenko to the Oval Office this month
he was chosen by the people of Ukraine
it was not the government of Kiev that
destabilized eastern Ukraine it's been
the pro-russian separatists who are
encouraged by Russia financed by Russia
trained by Russia supplied by Russia and
armed by Russia and the Russian forces
that have now moved into Ukraine are not
on a humanitarian or peacekeeping
mission they are Russian combat forces
with Russian weapons
in Russian tanks now these are the facts
they are provable they're not subject to
dispute as a result of state-run
propaganda many Russians have become
convinced that the actions taken by
their government is strengthening Russia
but reaching back to the days of his
arse trying to reclaim lands lost in the
19th century is surely not the way to
secure Russia's greatness in the 21st
century
it only shows that unrestrained
nationalism is the last refuge of those
who cannot or will not deliver real
progress and opportunity for their own
people at home let's also be clear where
we stand
just as we refuse to accept smaller
European nations being dominated by
bigger neighbors in the last century we
reject any talk of spheres of influence
today
and just as we never accepted the
occupation and illegal annexation of the
Baltic nations we will not accept
Russia's occupation and illegal
annexation of Crimea or any part of
Ukraine
as free peoples as an alliance we will
stand firm and United to meet the test
of this moment and here's how first we
will defend our NATO allies and that
means every Ally
in this lines there are no old members
or new members no junior partners or
senior partners
they're just allies pure and simple and
we will defend the territorial integrity
of every single Ally
today more NATO aircraft patrol the
skies of the Baltics more American
forces are on the ground training and
rotating through each of the Baltic
States more NATO ships patrol the Black
Sea tonight I depart for the NATO summit
in Wales and I believe our alliance
should extend these defensive measures
for as long as necessary because the
defense of Tallinn and Regan Vilnius is
just as important as the defense of
Berlin and Paris and London
during the long Soviet occupation the
greatest Oh nyan poet Maria under wrote
a poem in which she cried to the world
who'll come to help right here at
present now and I say to the people
Estonian people of the Baltics today we
are bound by our treaty alliance we have
a solemn duty to each other article 5 is
crystal-clear an attack on one is an
attack on all so if in such a moment you
ever ask again who will come to help
you'll know the answer the NATO alliance
including the armed forces of the United
States of America right here present now
we'll be here for Estonia we will be
here for Latvia we will be here for
Lithuania you lost your independence
once before with NATO you will never
lose it again
second and in addition to the measures
we've already taken the United States is
working to bolster the security of our
NATO allies and further increase
America's military presence in Europe
the new initiative I proposed in Warsaw
this spring includes several elements
and we're working with Congress to get
it done here in the Baltics it would
mean positioning more American equipment
so it's ready if needed it would mean
more training and exercises between our
militaries and it would mean more US
forces including American boots on the
ground continuously rotating through
Estonia Latvia and Lithuania third NATO
forces need the ability to deploy even
faster in times of crisis now this week
our alliance must unite around a new
plant and hence our readiness and that
means we need to step up our defence
planning so we're fully prepared for any
threat to any ally it also means we need
to have the infrastructure and
facilities that can receive rapid
reinforcements including here in the
Baltics we need to enhance NATO's Rapid
Response Force so it can deploy even
more quickly and not just react to
threats but also deter them and even as
we meet conventional threats we need to
face other challenges and that includes
propaganda campaigns to try to whip up
fears and divide people from one another
we reject the idea that people cannot
live and thrive together just because
they have different backgrounds or speak
a different language and the best
antidotes to such distorted thinking are
the values that define us not just in
the Baltics but throughout Europe we
must acknowledge the inherent dignity
and human rights of every person because
our democracies cannot truly succeed
until we root out bias and Prejudice
both from our institutions and from our
hearts we have to uphold a free press
and freedom of speech because in the end
lies and misinformation are no match for
the truth we have to embrace open and
inclusive societies because our
countries are more successful and more
prosperous when we welcome the talents
of all our people including minorities
that's part of the work that we must do
that's the example we must set forth
even as we keep our countries strong at
home we need to keep our alliance strong
for the future that means investing in
the capabilities like intelligence and
surveillance and reconnaissance and
missile defense and here in Europe
nations need to do more to spur the
growth and prosperity that sustains our
alliance to it's great credit Estonia
stands out as an ally that contributes
its full share its full two percent of
GDP to the defence of our alliance and
Latvia and Lithuania have pledged to do
the same so this week that's worth
applause
so this week's summit is the moment for
every NATO nation to step up and commit
to meeting its responsibilities to our
alliance Estonia does it every Ally must
do it fifth we must continue to stand
united against Russia's aggression in
Ukraine
keep in mind that repeatedly President
Putin has ignored the opportunity to
resolve the crisis in Ukraine
diplomatically the United States the
European Union our partners around the
world have all said we prefer a
diplomatic solution but in light of
Russia's unwillingness to seize that
opportunity we have come together to
impose major major sanctions on Russia
for its actions and make no mistake
Russia is paying a price capital is
fleeing foreign investment is plummeting
because investors know that today's
Russia is a bad bet given its behavior
the Russian economy has slipped in a
recession its energy production which is
the engine of the Russian economy is
expected to drop its credit rating is
near junk status the ruble just fell to
an all-time low in short Russia's
actions in Ukraine are weakening Russia
Russia's actions are hurting the Russian
people and it doesn't have to be this
way we have no interest in weakening
Russia it's a nation with a rich history
and a remarkable people we do not seek
out confrontation with Russia over the
past two decades the United States has
gone to great lengths to welcome Russia
into the community of nations and to
encourage its economic success we
welcome a Russia that is strong and
growing and contributes to international
security and peace and that resolves
disputes peacefully with diplomacy and
in contrast to Russia's isolation and
economic woes today that path which
would include a stable and prosperous
Ukraine whose sovereignty is respected
would also ultimately result in greatest
that's an opportunity and respect for
Russia that path remains available to
Russia that path will deliver true
progress for the Russian people but it's
a path that starts by Russia changing
course and leaving Ukraine
so that Ukrainians can make their own
decisions and I have no doubt that one
of their decisions would be to have
strong relations with not just Europe
but also with Russia but it has to be
freely chosen this brings me to the
final area where our nations have to
come together in our steadfast support
for those who reach for their freedom
and yes that includes the people of
Ukraine and few understand us better
than the Baltic people's you know from
bitter experience that we can never take
our security and liberties for granted
we want Ukrainians to be independent and
strong and able to make their own
choices free from fear and intimidation
because the more countries are free and
strong and free from intimidation the
more secure our own liberties are so the
United States will continue to help
Ukraine reform to escape a legacy of
corruption and build democratic
institutions to grow its economy and
like other European nations diversify
its energy sources because no country
should ever be held hostage to another
nation that wields energy like a weapon
we'll continue to offer training and
assistance to help the Ukrainian
military grow stronger as they defend
their country and since ultimately
there's no military solution to this
crisis we will continue to support
president poroshenko's efforts to
achieve peace because like all
independent nations Ukraine must be free
to decide its own destiny and this week
NATO must send an unmistakable message
in support of Ukraine as well our
alliance has had a partnership with
Ukraine for more than 20 years Ukrainian
forces have served with distinction and
NATO operations in the Balkans and
Afghanistan so in Wales we'll meet as an
alliance with president poroshenko to
show that our 28 nations are united in
support of Ukraine's sovereignty and
right to defend its territory now
Ukraine needs more than words NATO needs
to make concrete commitments to help
Ukraine modernize and strengthen its
security forces and by the way we have
to do more to help other NATO partners
including Georgia and Moldova strengthen
their defenses as well
and we must reaffirm the principle that
has always guided our alliance for
countries that meet our standards and
that can make meaningful contributions
to Allied security the door to NATO
membership will remain open so this is a
moment of testing the actions of the
separatists in Ukraine and Russia evoke
dark tactics from Europe's paths that
ought to be consigned to a distant
history masked mens storming buildings
soldiers without Flags slipping across
the border violence sending families
fleeing and killing thousands including
nearly 300 innocent men women and
children from all across Europe and
around the world when that airliner was
shot out of the sky in the face of
violence that seems intractable and
suffering that is so senseless it is
easy to grow cynical and I think
tempting to give in to the notion that
peace and security may be beyond our
grasp but I say to all of you here today
especially the young people do not give
in to that cynicism do not lose the
idealism and optimism that is the root
of all great change
don't ever lose the faith that says if
we want it if we are willing to work for
it if we stand together the future can
be different tomorrow can be better
after all the only reason we're here
today in a free and democratic Estonia
is because the Estonian people never
gave up you never gave up when the Red
Army came in from the east or when the
Nazis came in from the West
you never gave up when the Soviets came
back or when they sent your best and
brightest to the gulag never to return
you never gave up through a long
occupation that tried to break your
spirit and crush your culture their
tanks were no equal to the moral power
of your voices United in song their
walls were no match for the strength of
your people
United in that unbreakable chain like
the poles and Hungarians the Czechs and
the Slovaks and the East Germans on top
of that wall you were stronger and you
always believed one day no matter what
we will win today your example your
victory gives hope to people all over
the world yes there will be setbacks and
there will be frustrations and there
will be moments of doubt and moments of
despair the currents of history a band
flow but over time they flow toward
freedom more people in every corner of
the earth standing up and reaching to
claim those rights that are universal
and that's why in the end our ideals are
stronger and that's why in the end our
ideals will win dignity will win because
every human being is born equal with
free will and inalienable rights and any
regime or system of government that
tries to deny these rights will
ultimately
fail and countries that uphold them will
only grow stronger justice will win
because might does not make right and
the only path to lasting peace is when
people know that their dignity will be
respected and that their rights will be
upheld and citizens like nations will
never settle for a world where the
bigger are allowed to bully the small
sooner or later they fight back
democracy will win because the
government's legitimacy can only come
from citizens because in this age of
information and empowerment people want
more control over their lives not less
and because more than any other form of
government ever devised only democracy
rooted in the sanctity of the individual
can deliver real progress and freedom
will win not because it's inevitable not
because it is ordained but because these
basic human yearnings for dignity and
justice and democracy do not go away
they can be suppressed at times they can
be silenced but they burn in every human
heart in a place where no regime can
ever reach a light that no army can ever
extinguish and so long as free peoples
summon the confidence and the courage
and the will to defend the values that
we cherish then freedom will always be
stronger and our ideas will always
prevail no matter what thank you and
long live our great alliance thank you
very much thank you